scholar and author ira max candy is
bringing classic stories from an
acclaimed american writer to young
readers kennedy is adapting six stories
from zora neale hurston best known for
her 1937 novel their eyes were watching
god his first adaptations children's
book titled magnolia flower it's
beautiful beautiful illustrations the
story follows a young girl who is black
and native american looking for love and
freedom kendy's the founding director of
the boston university center for
anti-racist research and a cbs news
contributor it's great to see you in
person hello welcome back to new york
it's a pleasure to be here so you like
me our girl dan you got a six-year-old
at home yes and you told us that this
really was inspired by her tell us a
little bit more about that i mean i just
have long admired the work of zora neale
hurston
and i didn't want my i didn't want my
daughter to have to wait until she sort
of came of age to have to read the
stories that that zora
wrote the stories that she collected i i
wanted her to have the opportunity
to read a beautiful story like like
magnolia flower like right now even
though she's six years old and you say
that's part of your mission is to try to
bring these
literary classics to younger readers
faster in essence
why why now
as opposed to waiting until they're
older what's so important about making
sure they get exposed to this sooner
well i think in particular zoranil
hurston
you know wrote during a time in which it
was difficult for people to to have joy
it was
and and she her her writings were so
joyous her her her stories were were
filled with love and i think
particularly in this moment
to to share love stories with with
children that also allow them to learn
about history i think is a beautiful
thing
ibra my son is too he is biracial and i
started reading books about race to him
but sometimes i worry that he'll
eventually ask me a question i'm not
sure how to answer did your daughter in
this process i know you shared early
drafts with her ask you a question that
really impacted the story line or
surprised you
she asked me well i haven't i read about
this or heard about this sort of sooner
which i think only
inspired me me more to to ensure that
she's learning about this history
because even magnolia flower the
afro-indigenous girl uh who is the main
character
uh her her her parents one was enslaved
and one
had to flee the the trail of tears and
and so it opened up the opportunity for
us to learn about very critical moments
in in us history
you know the story is beautiful in that
it uses the imagery of it it compares a
river and a brook right and that's how
she that's what she uses to tell this
story what would you say to people
watching right now
who may think that
it's a little tough or hard they don't
know how to
teach young kids about race and racism
and what do you say to those who are
like you know what i don't think we need
to be doing that those who might push
back on it
well there are many things as parents
that's that's tough for us to talk to
our kids about like for instance
stranger danger like that's a very
difficult conversation for us to have
with our our children but it's important
right for us to to have those
conversations just like it's important
for us to have conversations with our
children about race and about history
and about african-american folklore like
like like the stories that zora
collected
this story is about a girl searching for
love and freedom in the face of
resistance why is that story so critical
right now particularly for children
because in many ways this girl magnolia
flower decided she was going to make a
way out of no way
she was going to ensure that love
was something that conquered all and and
i just think in this moment particularly
where there's
oftentimes hate sort of circling around
us we we we need love stories and we
need children uh who are who are
conquering all through love
we do well look evil max candy thank you
we really appreciate it like i said
gorgeous
illustrated by how do we pronounce your
first name love is wise
it's on sale tomorrow go check it out